some details like maybe like two weeks
ago there was a guy from Harvard
professor that got his name is George
dr. George Church okay he got busted for
taking money from China that's right he
was involved in like virus and bio
weapons you know that [ __ ] right you
know that guy in China they only have
one like bio lab like level four is one
and one so no no no this professor gets
busted for taking all this money from
China you know who else was giving him
millions in new wounds and dollars Oh
Jeffrey Epstein really he was giving him
the professor dr. George Church bro but
Jeffrey Epstein was given a lot of
people money well check this out
Jeffrey Epstein was black I was in his
job was to blackmail politicians
celebrities and scientists we're like
why would you block why would you
blackmail why would he blackmail a
politician for instance why would you do
that because you want certain things why
would you blackmail celebrity cuz you
want them to what I enjoyed something
you want why would you blackmail into
celebrity because they have sway right
if they can influence
why would you blackmail scientists okay
you want to [ __ ] them you want
information now you want to [ __ ] them
right or you want them to create some
sort of hat okay let's back up
we're blackmailing politicians look
Jamie has up here no link between
Harvard scientist Charles Lieber and the
coronavirus that means there's a link
[Laughter]
scientist was charged for lying about
his participation in a Chinese
recruitment program and his affiliation
with Chinese university is not accused
of being a spy he is that's not the guy
I'm talking about I'm talking about dr.
George Church I know looked him up I
didn't guys
do you know the crazy thing is is okay I
mean shut the [ __ ] I know it's about the
[ __ ] Modelo virus do you know that
Spears new album you don't think science
just made up the coronavirus y'all think
Chinese I think viruses can sometimes
spring up on their own yep the only bio
lab that deals with that in China is in
whoo that is true that's the only one
there there are legitimate scientists
that are speculating that this might
have been something that was
accidentally released from lab and
although they don't contain those things
very well particularly when you're
dealing with a country like China that
doesn't have the same sort of standards
that like when you have in galveston at
the CDC Center where they have things
like Ebola and all these different
things in the containment they have
incredibly strict procedures they used
to handle that stuff loosey-goosey they
didn't that main guy who was dealing
with coronavirus that the Chinese got he
died for me it was blowing the whistle
on the corona virus and then he was
censured by the Chinese government did
die
they probably yeah oh he died of a
[ __ ] Club the corona virus